en este vídeo quiero hablar de cómo
podemos visualizar cierta muestra de
datos que nos den en particular vamos a
usar algo que se llama el diagrama de
tallo y de hojas el diagrama de tallo y
de hojas sale y lo que es útil de este
diagrama es que nos permite entender la
información mucho mejor de una manera
visual porque no las muestra en una
cierta disposición de árbol de la cual
podemos leer varias cosas por ejemplo
podemos saber más o menos cómo está
distribuida o más o menos por donde está
el promedio aquí arriba tenemos un
cierto conjunto de datos que nos dieron
que al principio está como muy revuelto
realmente no entiendo muy bien cómo
están distribuidos
hay varios 40 algunos unos algunos 80
así así pero no en que no muy bien con
lo cual es su media cuál es su moda o
mediana ni nada no entiendo para nada
este conjunto de números entonces
utilizando un diagrama de tallo y hojas
con un poco de suerte vamos a aclarar un
poco cómo se comporta este conjunto de
números
la idea es para empezar de estos números
de estos números que tenemos aquí
encontrarles el dígito significativo lo
primero que notamos es que todos estos
números
son menores que siente pero qué más
podemos decir empezando con los números
chiquitos por ahí vemos un 2 y por acá
vemos un 1 y ahí pues hay muchos números
pero creo que el más grande es este 84
ahora si nos damos cuenta hay varios
números en medio hay algunos 2030 así
60s como todos los números están en este
rango tenemos que el dígito
significativo es de las escenas muy bien
ya acabamos con la primer parte
empecemos nuestro diagrama de tallo y
hojas escribiendo por aquí decenas sale
y entonces el dígito de las decenas
puede ser 0 1 2 3 4 lo voy a escribir un
poquito más grande puede ser 0 1 2 3 4 5
7 voy a recorrer hacia abajo un poquito
la pantalla 7 u 8 verdad
saleh estos dígitos van a representar el
tallo de nuestro diagrama de gen
encerrarlo entre dos líneas una línea
por aquí y otra línea por acá y este va
a ser el tallo de nuestro diagrama saleh
lo voy a poner por aquí y le voy a poner
que se llama el el tallo
y para un número como 1 el dígito de las
escenas es 0 para un número como 84 el
dígito de las escenas es 8 sale entonces
ahora lo que quiero hacer es pasar toda
esta información a nuestro diagrama
entonces cómo le hacemos para hacer esto
ahorita les muestro la técnica creo que
lo mejor es enseñarse los con algunos
ejemplos supongamos que queremos poner
el 35 el dígito de las escenas de 35 es
entonces en el renglón de 3 vamos a
poner un 5 que es la del dígito de las
unidades esto nos dice que 35 es uno de
los números ahora tenemos 42 lo tachamos
42 en el renglón 4 ponemos el dígito de
las unidades como una hoja ahora ponemos
el 38 va en el renglón 3 aquí ponemos el
38 y no tenemos que reescribir el 3 de
las escenas ya tenemos un 35 ya tenemos
un 38 y solo tuvimos que escribir el
dígito de las unidades aquí en el
renglón del 3 o si quieren en el cajón
del 3 sigamos con la lista hay que
copiar un 57 57 luego siguió un 2
su dígito de las decenas de 0.02 ahora
vamos con el 24 aquí en el renglón del
24 ahora tenemos un 27 lo ponemos por
aquí 27 con 36 lo copiamos en el renglón
3 36 35 un 38 en 36 son 45 45 ahora va
un 60 lo ponemos aquí creo que ya viste
la idea pero vamos a seguir copiando los
38 y 38 40 va en el renglón del 444 40
40 para un 44 aquí lo ponemos 44 aquí
hay un 101 otro 44 44 ahora van 48 48 ya
van varias cosas en los 40s un 84 84
ahora va un 38 un 38
sigue un 20 aquí 2020
un 4 activada 04 ahora 12 aquí en el 0
02 48 48 está un poco aburrido esto pero
sigamos 58 un 58 va a un 303 vámonos con
el siguiente renglón hay un 2020 ahora
un 60 6 ahora otro 40 más allá hay un 40
un 22 22 habrá un 26 aquí tenemos un 26
para un 17 lo copiamos lo copiamos en el
renglón del 1 miren es el primero con 17
un 18 hasta 18 hará un 40 un 40
ahora un 51 1 un 51 y 62 aquí va a 62 a
un 31 1 31 para el 27 27 ahora van 48 48
ya se están juntando muchas cosas aquí
verdad 35 con 35
27 27 ya casi terminamos un 37 58 58 y
ya nada más un número más el 21 este lo
ponemos en el cajón del 2 por aquí 21 y
ya está bueno estaba un poco aburrido
copiar los números pero simplemente lo
que hicimos fue reescribir esta
información en nuestro diagrama fíjate
como cada número está representada aquí
aquí podemos leer todos los números que
tenemos en la lista de arriba verdad por
ejemplo tenemos un 6 tenemos un 27
tenemos un 38 un 35 entonces no hemos
perdido nada de la información de
nuestra lista lo que está más padre de
esta disposición son dos cosas número
uno es que logramos ahorrarnos tinta y
escritura porque no hay que escribir
tantas decenas pero lo más importante es
que ya entendemos mucho mejor cómo están
distribuidos estos números hay muchos
números por los 20 30 y 40 ahí se
acumula casi toda la lista hay poquitos
acá en los 60 70 y 80
hay unos poquitos bueno hay algunos en
los dígitos de las unidades pero de
todas formas casi todos están
concentrados
2 en los 20 30 y 40 bueno esta es una de
las muchas muchas formas que existen
para visualizar información espero que
te haya gustado y que te sirva para
entender tus futuras muestras